we have two very very special
presentations for you today because we
are saying goodbye to producer Lewis who
is going to be moving on to warmer and
less urban areas of the world which has
been determined to be a top priority in
your next thing so to speak and the
first presentation is something that has
been produced by intern and segment
producer John Anderson who has been
doing a heck of a job job and it's
talked to us John about what this is and
how it got its name
Bistro Linguistics well it's a
compilation of you and Lewis talking
about food which was clearly day one I
could tell that that was something very
near and dear to both of your hearts and
then when David told me to do that I
don't remember exactly where Bistro
Linguistics came from I was actually
reading the I was reading the third
hitchhikers book at the time I believe
and they have that like Bistro Drive or
whatever in that so I think that's where
it entered my head at first quite a
backstory till I really I guess that's
probably where it came from so yeah I
just kind of categorized everything
through them together and it came out
pretty good I have to say all right so
with no further delay I present to you
the first part of our two-part of
special episode dedicated to Lewis this
is Bistro linguistics edited by John
Anderson
let's take a look Louis would you
describe yourself as a fan of peanut
butter huge fan yes
it's it's a great product not just for
putting on crackers or celery with
raisins but for cooking as well
love broccoli not a fan of its white
cousin cauliflower but I'm a big fan of
the duck to David I missed the days of
jelly bean you know I am a fan yeah I
like jelly beans
I am NOT a fan of Cascia I'm a big fan
of sushi have been for a long time I'm
not a fan either I like I do like
cauliflower um let's see
beaver beaver but glands the way I
usually like epithelium is sprinkled
with paprika and roasted over an open
flame I want meat a salad almost it's
covered in bacon crumpled cheese and
some type of extremely heavy cream base
dressing yeah a plain yogurt you know a
Greek yogurt is very high in protein
don't go crazy Louis they're going to
figure out that there's other stuff
other than broccoli and quinoa ground
aren't they a can of tuna with some
other stuff also very high in protein I
was definitely a member of the clean
plate Club just tuna out of a can that
to me would seem incredibly unsavory I I
took pride in cleaning my plate I'll add
some nuts and seeds you're a big boy you
finished all your food yeah that's great
yeah I am a big boy look what I finished
all my food everybody's familiar with
Olive Garden the horrible Italian style
restaurant that exists in that you are
so bad you're supposedly an Italian
restaurant and you're not salting the
pasta water this is just a Maine it's a
it's just a basic thing you know my
pasta dish is supposed to have
vegetables in it and stuff and and
peppers there was one square of pepper
that the food at Olive Garden is a
disaster it is overpriced it was not a
consistency consistent with meat would
call me the pasta appeared to not even
really be pasta milk and beans included
bagels are a much worse than let's say
you know a couple slices of healthier
wheat bread five pound bag or package of
jelly beans hot dogs
stuffed crust pizza pizza yeah or burger
hot dogs yeah okay and the hot dogs
appear to be sort of uh well yeah it's
it's they're wrapped in crust obviously
thin crust pizzas one of one of my
favorite pizzas is the the the margarita
miniature hot dog weenies I don't like
the sausage or the pepperonis and that
those types of things on my pizza going
to Pizza Hut to get
Pizza right which is which is heinous in
and of itself Pizza Huts you culinary
abominations I could I could blow them
out of the water right some people make
the green bean casserole my family has
never done that Dairy bread meat fruit
vegetables we usually just make just
plain green beans fried chicken
watermelon cornbread and also collard
greens I mean you got your salad like
you said your pumpkin pie sweet potato
pie
sometimes mashed potatoes chocolate milk
frozen ice cream they owned the company
that makes Laffy Taffy which are fine
put some gravy on that rapid rap of
kappa you know that these huge mocha
stuffing should definitely have some
apple in it creamy tomato soup with
fresh basil got the cranberry sauce a
squash turkey do not put the next bite
on your fork until you've swallowed the
current bite that's probably a mess
yogurts bacon grease and it is it's the
fixed stuff yeah I'm into every kind of
dim sum there is four shrimp peeled and
deveined raw like the whale I had for
example lose like a steak is just like a
slab of red meat one thing you can
always do is when you walk into a
restaurant look at other people's sushi
very closely before you order and then
you'll know it's perfectly acceptable to
go right up to a couple that's eating
and just put your face right up and see
what the sushi looks like I've had
jellyfish oh no it's a good piece of
fish it'll just almost melt in your
mouth gotta love that chicken bone
tissue Luis gotta love that crispy
roasted chicken David everyone loves
fried chicken except people who are
repulsed by me mechanically separated
chicken we've talked about tuna scrape
disgusting gelatinous chicken what was
the goal of a meal of fried chicken and
watermelon olive oil soap for the shower
the avocado is going to add a lot to
whatever it is I'm eating ten five
gallon tubs of coconut oil I do I put
chia seeds with nuts and usually some
honey in the yogurt potatoes a hair in
your soup applying your potatoes Brown
the potatoes
I had a potato that was completely soft
so like I mentioned we want to avoid the
potatoes from getting brown me
personally no because I don't eat fast
food
okay I find that I need to speak up
whenever I see someone eating fast food
really my claim to fame is it's been
about 14 years since I've eaten anything
from the McDonald's well first of all
the food it's not food it's just not
food everything they sell is complete
garbage
this incident doesn't make me any less
likely to go to Taco Bell Taco Bell
where the food is just an abomination
and people think that that's actual
Mexican food basically don't go to any
McDonald of course and the only people
that are saying McDonald's is is healthy
or good are McDonald's spokespeople well
I think we can objectively say that
McDonald's is crap
yeah pinch the top instead of the bottom
you get the whole thing that way you
know and then just take the top off
that's it you guys a whole behalf yeah
Luis doesn't care if you like this is
really interesting
I thought it was new I mean monkeys yeah
monkeys have been doing amazing Louis I
mean an unbelievable summation of all of
the different culinary discussions that
have taken place on the show yes and in
doing his research for this john
admitted that we have been very
consistent over the years did you find
that john that there has not been
flip-flopping on food-related matters
there definitely has and everywhere I
looked it was like McDonald's bashing
and fast-food bashing in general I
couldn't find I couldn't find any
instance where one of you said you hated
something and then came back and liked
it alright well I think for that we can
all be proud yes it's a masterfully done
John thank you well